in the 20 plus years since their time in
Genovia the cast of The Princess Diaries
have racked up resumés full of Industry
accolades and pretty much every
cinematic genre imaginable following her
onscreen debut on the short-lived fox
show get real Anne Hathaway got her big
break as Mia Thermopolis in The Princess
Diaries in 2001 then in 2004 she had a
pair of Princess parts in The Princess
Diaries 2 and Ella Enchanted though she
soon branched out to n Royal roles as
well from comedies like the devil worst
Prada and Bride Wars to collaborating
with Christopher Nolan on The Dark
Knight Rises and Interstellar pathaway
has reliably demonstrated her range over
the years she even won an Oscar for best
supporting actress for 2012's lay M Rob
which allowed her to show off both her
acting and singing skills offscreen
hathway is passionate about activism
particularly as an advocate for equal
opportunities for women and girls
especially the right to an education in
2016 she was appointed a United Nations
women Goodwill Ambassador Julie Andrews
already had a glittering decades long
career before she played the queen of
Genovia the legendary star of stage and
Screen became a household name in
1964 when she played the titel magical
nanny in Disney's Mary Poppins for which
she won an Oscar for best lead actress
following The Princess Diaries and it
equal Andrew has mostly focused on voice
acting bringing her instantly
recognizable voice to franchises like
shre and Despicable Me more recently she
voiced The Mysterious lady whistle down
on the Netflix series Bridgerton and at
spin-off Queen Charlotte a Bridgerton
story away from the screen Andrews is a
prolific author as she released two
Memoirs and she's co-written several
children's books with her daughter Emma
Walton Hamilton head of security Joe is
a steadfast and calming presence in The
Princess Diaries and the guy who played
him Hector alzando is a similarly
reliable presence in director Gary
Marshall's movies from 1982's Young
doctors in love to 2016's Mother's Day
alzando has shown up in 18 of Marshall's
films in a 2016 interview with variety
about their working relationship alzando
said Gary kept reminding people how
lucky we are to be working he liked
hiring the same people because you don't
have to explain stuff elzando has also
carved out a successful voice acting
career in movies like The Lego Batman
movie and TV shows like Elena of avalor
and from 2011 to 2021 he had a recurring
role on the sitcom Last Man Standing
Alando is proud of his Latino Heritage
but he's careful about the roles he
chooses and refuses to play into
stereotypes as he told the Washington
Post in 1999 by putting me in that box
by categorizing me you're taking away my
options and my opportunity if I may say
so that did not go very well in The
Princess Diaries Mandy Moore plays the
cheerleader Lana Thomas who mercilessly
picks on Mia and her friends she and her
cohorts rule the school and to make
matters even worse she's dating Mia's
Crush Josh when the princess diaries
came out Moore was more well known for
her music but in the Years her acting
career has really taken off with leading
roles in films Like A Walk to Remember
chasing Liberty and saved in 2010 Moore
voiced the Disney Princess Rapunzel
entangled and in 2016 she landed perhaps
the most iconic role of her career
Rebecca Pearson on the NBC drama this is
us since then she's also starred in The
Shark Thriller 47 m down and the war
drama Midway at first glance M as
parents have a lot to answer for in
terms of why they kept the secret of her
royal Heritage away from her for so long
but the film eventually reveals that her
mother Helen did it so that her daughter
could have a normal childhood or at
least as normal as living in a converted
Firehouse could be she also
single-handedly raised Mia while her
ex-husband was heir to a fictional
European country Helen is a
free-spirited artist who ultimately
proves to be very supportive of her
daughter's journey to becoming a
princess before playing Helen Caroline
Goodall notably appeared in two Steven
Spielberg movies 1991's hook and 1993's
Schindler's List since the princess
diaries came out in 2001 her credits
include the Feelgood feline flick a
street cat named Bob and the Stars
historical miniseries the White Queen
and the white princess even though
there's a compelling argument that Lily
moskovitz is the True Villain of The
Princess Diaries she's generally one of
the most consistent people in Mia's life
Lily is quirky and eccentric as she
proudly marches to the beat of Her Own
Drum and that's all thanks to the
winning performance of Heather
matazo shut up shut up shut up matazo
began her onscreen career at the age of
11 on a couple of episodes of The
Adventures of Pete and Pete then her big
screen break came in 1995 with welcome
to the dollhouse she also played Martha
Meeks in Scream 3
a part that she reprised in the fifth
film in that series since the princess
diaries matarazo has mostly acted in
lowbudget Indies and she's been very
open about her struggles in Hollywood as
she told the guardian in 2017 most
people think that I probably get paid a
lot of money but I really don't and most
working actors don't sometimes a
character needs just a handful of scenes
to make an unforgettable impact and
that's certainly the case with
flamboyant hairdresser Paulo who was was
played by character actor Larry Miller
he was memorable enough in the first
film to reprise his role in the sequel
despite having already worked his magic
with Mia's makeover and subsequently
disgraced himself when he sold her out
to the Press however Paulo's intentions
are sort of honorable as he just wants
the world to see and appreciate his
incredible work on Mia's locks outside
of Genovia Miller is perhaps best known
as cat and Bianca's dad in 10 Things I
Hate About You he's also been a regular
in the mockumentary films directed by
Christopher Guest like Best in Show and
he was a regular on Gary Marshall's
roster as he showed up in the likes of
raising Helen and Valentine's Day in
addition to all that Miller has enjoyed
a successful stand-up comedy career and
appeared on TV shows like Curb Your
Enthusiasm there's one memorable moment
in the princess diaries that tells us
pretty much everything we need to know
about the character of Michael mosovich
he fixes cars he plays guitar and he can
in he is so hot he is wicked sweet
Michael is the older brother of Mia's
best friend Lily who admires Mia from
afar until eventually she realizes that
the boy who can make her foot pop has
been there all along Michael might not
come from a royal background but the
same can't be said for the guy who
played him Robert schwarzman who's a
member of American cinem of royalty his
mom is Talia Shire which means Francis
Ford Copa is one of his uncles his
cousins include Sophia Copa and Nicholas
Cage and his older brother is Jason
schwarzman compared to some of his
castmates Robert schwarzman hasn't been
quite as prolific on screen since the
princess diaries however he still
enjoyed a successful career as the lead
singer of the alt rock band Rooney and
he's also directed several films
including 2016's Dreamland which starred
his brother Jason the flame-haired
Jeremiah Hart is a friend of Mia and
Lily and another one of the outcasts at
Grove High School he also appears
alongside Lily on her cable talk show
shut up and listen where he shows off
his impressive abilities as a magician
the actor who played him Patrick John
fluger didn't return for The Princess
Diaries 2o but he's managed to steady
career since the release of the first
movie after some minor TV guest roles he
landed a major part on the Sci-Fi series
The
4400 and then he showed up in the 2011
remake of foot loose he now has a
regular role on Chicago PD as Adam rusic
a character who's also shown up on
Chicago Med and Chicago Fire tasked with
simmering down a debate class near the
beginning of The Princess Diaries is
Grove High's English teacher Mr oconnell
following Mia's stage fright in his
class during which she almost vomits
into a tuba a surprising turn of events
later sees Mr oconnell dating Mia's mom
Helen after playing Mr oconnell in The
Princess Diaries and its sequel Shan
O'Brien has appeared in a variety of
other films including yes man searching
and Olympus has fallen in addition to
the two Princess Diaries movies he's
worked with director Gary Marshall twice
more since then in New Year's Eve in
2011 and Mother's Day in
2016 every early O Teen Movie needs a
hottie for the protagonist to chase
after and in the princess diaries that
hottie comes in the form of Eric Von
Deton as Josh Bryant while Mia spends
her days fantasizing about making out
with Josh he barely gives her a second
look until her radical transformation
Josh Bryant that Backstreet Boy clone
you've had a crush on forever okay he is
not a Backstreet Boy clone he's a sailor
Von Deon got his big break in the early
'90s on the soap opera Days of Our Lives
and then he spent the majority of his
teen years working with Disney as he
appeared in the made for TV skating
movie brain and the Supernatural TV show
so weird outside of those credits he's
perhaps best known as the voice of the
villainous Sid in Toy Story and Toy
Story 3 the latter proved to be his last
role as veton has since retired from
acting he now works in finance and is
married to Los Angeles realtor Angela
Von but he hasn't completely ruled out a
return to acting as he told E news in
2021 if there's a script with a role
that doesn't require an arduous audition
process I'm definitely open even though
the prince Diaries is a teen movie The
Adult characters are just as memorable
and one of the best has to be sassy vice
principal Gupta in just over 2 minutes
of screen time Sandra o completely
steals the show
GTA mhm
mm The Queen Is Coming o is now a huge
star in her own right especially thanks
to all those years she played Dr
Christina Yang on G's anatomy and her
starring role as the title character on
the Thriller series killing Eve she's
also had memorable vocal turns and
animated flicks like turning red if
there's ever a third Princess Diaries
movie oh would jump at the chance to
come back as she told Entertainment
Weekly in 2023 I am ready for the queen
call me I'm dying to see how Gupta has
moved up in the world not only did
director Gary Marshall Lov working with
the same actors over and over during the
course of his career he also loved
working with his family for example his
daughter Kathleen Marshall pops up in
The Princess Diaries as Charlotte
cutaway the headset wearing right-hand
woman to Queen Clarice since young
doctors in love in 1982 Kathleen has
appeared in almost all of her dad's
movies following Gary's death in 2016
Kathleen has helped preserve her
father's Legacy since 2017 she served on
the board at the Gary Marshall Theater
formerly the Falcon Theater which was
founded by her father that same year she
and her brother Scott accepted the
Disney Legend award on their father's
behalf and in 2018 she stood in for him
at the opening of Pretty Woman the
musical in Chicago although she's now
heavily involved in this behindth scenes
work Kathleen has expressed her
willingness to return to the franchise
should there ever be another Princess
Diaries as she enthused during an
interview on the hey now hey now podcast
in 2020 I'm ready to show up as
Charlotte